thank you
uh okay so I found this this morning and
I sent it to Marsh
um this is um
this is in Maine and this woman is
insane
she went to the Hell's Angels
headquarters in her in her local town
oh God and did this this woman is
[__]
so
this is the Hell's Angels ma'am ma'am
making me nervous just watching this
because it's like I wouldn't have
stopped and asked those gentlemen for
directions no you know what I mean also
it's probably a good idea that like if
you're spying on people
don't roll up in your car hold your arm
out the window with your camera and go
this is where the hell
angels are that's yeah man you approach
well so the thing is like and the thing
is like bikers will for the most part
just keep to themselves anyway like yeah
I know all right I do the criminal stuff
or whatever but for the most part like I
grew up around [__] pagans and [__]
and um and then I ran a bar for them
years later and it's like they keep to
themselves like they have their own
little [__] usually like they got
their own little compound they go hang
out on and you know they get drunk and
they do that math or whatever but
they're not like [__] bothering
people usually you know what I mean
that's right people is when they're
rolling through town a hundred of them
and you have to listen to 100 bikes and
not only that I looked up where this
compound was it's in the middle of
nowhere so it's not like it's in a
resident ancient neighbor they're not
bothering anybody no they're not in
Portland Maine they're just like the
[__] Backwoods somewhere
um compound
maybe it's really what you want to be
doing okay dude they're moving into the
suburbs of Maine and I like that they
approach her calmly like hey what are
you doing yeah don't even start off like
crazy bikers they're just like hey what
are you doing
and they're expanding into the suburbs
of Maine they're not though per the FBI
they're in Maine they are an outlawed
motorcycles of Maine what are you doing
like it's a fair question I'm not using
an assigned with the criminal bikers but
no I say property and they're like what
are you doing I side with that and the
guy on the left has a bull whip in his
hand which is my favorite run away can
you please get away from my vehicle you
you went to them can you imagine if I
were to go like to just [__] pork and
beans project in Miami and just start
filming them selling drugs and then I go
why are you coming towards my car
all right it's my fault the what project
okay over town look it up this it's the
the most famous the most dangerous
project in Overtown is called pork and
beans oh my God you're right Liberty
Square often referred to as the pork and
beans yeah so that's where like Uncle
Luke Liberty City yeah yeah yeah papa
that's where all the [__] that's like
the worst part of Miami is that project
that that area remember the Y remember
the projects are in The Wire what is
that it's like that Carol City a whole
little area it's just like oh it's the
Rick Ross territory that's it's bad
that was uh
that was more near Bayside into the
suburbs of Maine what are you doing well
yeah no I guess it's not that far
because bayside's not far from where it
might have been you might be right
actually
no that's not Ryan long can you please
get away from my vehicle can you get
away from what's Cameron hey buddy like
why are you filming me but like I'm just
you know we're out here we're doing like
motorcycle stuff
do you think trans people should be like
bikers
do you think Jack should have killed
clay
All Sons of Anarchy questions yeah
can you get away from my vehicle the
[__] camera out of here get away from
my vehicle get the camera out of here
get away from my vehicle both of you
what's your problem get away from my
vehicle right now get away from my
vehicle
you're talking to the Hell's Angels like
this man listen here Buckaroo exactly
[__] watching your we better watch it
right now listen here Buster Brown I do
not have to it's got like old lady
[__] Citizen and what I'm doing is
legal not your business move away from
my vehicle right now
I suggest you get the [__] out of here
ma'am ma'am you're saying are you
threatening me to a criminal
organization yeah a internationally
recognized criminal organization ma'am
yes they are three
ma'am ma'am what are you doing ma'am I
I'm I'm
ma'am you're playing a very dangerous
game right now
are so lame
get out mind your business mind your
business so if you go to a YouTube
channel she's [__] nuts
this is this is more recent but she had
a video from 2019 where she was yelling
at the cops because she said that if
somebody was stalking her from the
Hell's Angels broke into her house
drugged her and raped her and the cop's
like ma'am there's literally no evidence
of that so this woman is nuts but it's
there's a lot of crazy people but this
woman is is like being a crazy person
and actively calling the Yakuza a bunch
of zipper heads like why would you do
that you [__] [__] imagine being in
a [__] in the Hell's Angels and
you're gonna have to file a [__]
restraining order against some old lady
oh my God that would be the Hell's
Angels Hell's Angels leave us alone man
all right now we're seeing here the next
Once from the docket the Hell's Angel
LLC versus Gladys McGillicuddy
all right it says here the Hell's Angels
is filing a restraining order because
there's some just [__] big old
broad-shouldered old guy with long hair
and a beard with this [__] cut on and
your honor we just wanted to leave us
alone okay I mean we're just trying to
run a business and then your honor she
said
I probably ride a three-wheel
excuse me
saying this old lady is disrupting your
organization well yeah your honor uh we
had a toy run scheduled for the kids for
Christmas this year and This Woman's
just [__] our [__] up told to leave
us alone please
okay let's say how synthesizers arguing
with the Yakuza who did your ink Toshi a
blind [__] yes
also you know what I did you know what I
recommend go to the go to go to like
really mafioso types in like Jersey and
come with a bunch of stupid guidos and
tell them that Italians are actually
black people see how they come see how
they come at you
be so funny and then she trust such
accusing them in court like well these
bikers are like uh they're doing all
this illegal [__] they're growing
marijuana and they'll be like is that
true and they'll be like uh yeah your
honor we have a business license
[__] hilarious we're doing I mean
yeah if you want to come check it out
it's fine but everything we're doing is
legal and you know the best part is to
go but can it be at 6 PM because we're
doing a soup Drive yeah and we're doing
a motorcycle Toys for Tots this year too
so we're really like you know
okay we're busy very busy busy timing
here we just really need this woman to
stop disrupting our completely above
board business I like the idea of the
lawyer being dressed in a super with a
cut on though I really love would love
that look
mind your business get out of the road
get out of the road
uh this is a two dollars from the
cynical negro I know I'm just a black
guy here but am I the only one who
thinks white [__] think their ovaries
are a shield against any form of
violence Justified or otherwise I don't
know well that that only goes to show me
that those white chicks have never dated
a black guy
yeah they'll learn someday you know you
know who learns that the wives of cops
well you got issues huh no you I love
that the house Angels guys like ma'am
are you okay do we need to get help yeah
you're all kinds of [__] up lady
look ma'am we just like sell drugs and
we pimp out some [__] I mean that's
about it you seem a little crazy get an
athlete get the [__] out of here
and she's not leaving
yo and then like in the comics or
comments there's some people that are
like she's Brave standing up to those
standing up to those evil [__]
criminals I'm like it's one thing to
stand up to those criminals if they're
extorting old people's businesses but
it's another thing if they're in their
own compound right with a fence probably
just smoking weed and the guy was
probably breaking bottles with his bull
whip you know
like leave leave them alone yeah it's
not like they surrounded This Woman's
car oh no you're at their place and by
the way I looked up where they are it is
out of the way it's not like she ran
into them being their territory you can
see the severity of their aggression and
how many I'll be honest with you just
like you Marshall you said earlier I've
known a couple Hells Angels people
they're really nice dudes and here's the
other thing that I'm sure you know a lot
of Hell's Angels guys former military a
lot a lot of them are yeah I mean
they're criminals they're criminals that
want to be left alone and I'm fine you
know I'm fine with that they're
generally not [__] the kind of
criminals we see all the time on uh
viral videos
oh it's like all up in your [__] face
and they're all up [__] trash and
getting in [__] brawls in the middle
of your Mall you know it's it's [__]
they just like sell meth and they hang
out in their little compound in the
woods leave them alone they stand with a
five dollar donation merch can you
please do an impression of Mark Wahlberg
being a concerned citizen filming the
whole thing
yeah I'm tired I'm tired of this crime
in this community what's going on
these guys gotta become good Catholics
now let me get in my crazy amount of
steroids that I'm gonna take for my next
role I was getting up at full in the
morning so I could work out no I'm
saying these motorcycles turns out if
you work out and you if you lived hard
enough the Gay Thoughts go away in your
head it worked for me I'm not gay no
more
that's how I'm able to forgive myself
for not stopping 911 when I could
you know if I was there there wouldn't
have been a holocaust I would have just
get quickly in the face
done
I would have broke her to deal with the
ATF and and the Branch Davidians I could
have done it you should have brought me
in I would have fixed it
I could have negotiated
[Music]
what are you doing
man you got out of the car
huh what the [__] are you doing the
house Angel has moved into the suburb
can I say something else about the
Hell's Angels compound
well manicured
tip top shape like barricade garage yeah
herbs of names so they're expanding
their territory you can see the severity
mestizo [__] your wife a whole Mexican
their aggression and how many of them
have come out here
and so this is their compound and
they're involved for the FBI illegal
human trafficking
illegal drugs I was saying this earlier
today for certain thing else but we
really need to
update that update the way we're using
the word human trafficking and sex
trafficking because it's already been I
know like ruined you know when human
trafficking and sex trafficking used to
mean they would take women from their
families in other countries usually
bring them over your container ships and
make them work off their [__] debt
for food while while they they're
basically slaves indentured servitudes
that's what sexual things Sports and all
that [__] and they just keep everything
from them and being a pimp to three
strippers at the dollhouse is not sex
traffickers you know what I'm saying
though no you're right like it's not but
they call that everything sex
trafficking now it's not everything's
not when I worked in South Florida is
what the only time where I really saw
pimping being like more commonplace I
mean it's everywhere in the strip club
business but in Miami it was like
everyone had a pimp and like
those most of those women were free to
go
it wasn't like a [__] you know what I
mean it's like you're free to go at any
time apparently they said Hell's Angels
did run is that true that they really
run kids at one point I bet I doubt it
I'm not going to doubt that the criminal
organization didn't do that you know
uh trafficking
okay 50 Hells Angels go go on trial in a
case alleging prostitution murder
trafficking and other crimes in Spain
okay but I don't think the Portland I
don't think the one in Maine was doing
it
did you know there was Hell's Angels in
Spain yeah they're all over the world
yeah the Netherlands are all over Europe
they're in Australia yeah
so are the pagans
those are the ones that uh worst of the
Vikings right and say that Christmas is
actually a pagan holiday no not the
actual Pig oh okay yeah not those guys
bikers you mean the cool ones not the
skate ones honestly the pagans are the
cooler biker guy I agree only because
they have the cooler logo that's what I
said they have like the Norse god with
the [__] flaming Hammer it's like
okay that's pretty [__] if you can
have a logo man it's pretty [__]
badass